we've already seen Super Mario maker
levels from game developers and super
fans alike but there's a new level out
today from a creator you wouldn't expect
Nintendo's partnership with
mercedes-benz extends beyond Mario Kart
8 as the luxury car manufacturer has
released a new course titled
mercedes-benz jump and drive as you can
see in the screenshot the level sports
the mercedes-benz iconic logo made out
of bricks completing this level will
also unlock a new mystery mushroom
costume that puts Mario in the driver's
seat of a gla the level in costume are
both completely free and available right
now the level was designed within
mercedes-benz headquarters by Super
Mario maker fans but is not the first
time the Nintendo game has featured a
corporate made level Facebook released
its own level earlier this year we don't
cover automobiles very often but for
everything super mario maker related
keep it locked at gamespot.com i'm tony
wilson you can find me on twitter at
chain-gun Pope and I've got more courses
to build